the following is a conversation with
manolis kellis his fourth time on the
podcast
he's a professor at mit and head of the
mit computational biology group
since this is episode number 142
and 42 as we all know is the answer to
the ultimate question of life the
universe and everything
according to the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy
we decided to talk about this
unanswerable question of the meaning of
life
in whatever way we two descendants of
apes could muster
from biology to psychology to
metaphysics
and to music quick mention of each
sponsor
followed by some thoughts related to the
episode thanks to
grammarly which is a service for
checking
spelling grammar sentence structure and
readability
athletic greens the all-in-one drink
that i start every day with to cover all
my nutritional bases
and cash app the app i use to send money
to friends
please check out these sponsors in the
description to get a discount and
to support this podcast as a side note
let me say that the opening 40 minutes
of the conversation are
all about the many songs that formed the
soundtrack to the journey
of monolith's life it was a happy
accident for me to discover
yet another dimension of depth to the
fascinating mind of manolas
i include links to youtube versions of
many of the songs we mentioned
in the description and overlay lyrics on
occasion
but if you're just listening to this
without listening to the songs or
watching the video
i hope you still might enjoy as i did
the passion that manolis has for music
his singing of the little excerpts from
the songs
and in general the meaning we discuss
that we pull from the different songs if
music is not your thing
i do give timestamps to the less musical
and more philosophical parts of the
conversation
i hope you enjoy this little
experimenting conversation about
music and life if you do please
subscribe on youtube
review it with five stars on apple
podcast follow on spotify
support on patreon or connect with me on
twitter at lex friedman
and now here's my conversation with
manolas
kellis you mentioned leonard cohen and
the song hallelujah as a beautiful song
so what are the three songs you draw the
most meaning from
about life don't get me started
so there's really countless songs that
have marked me
that have sort of shaped me in periods
of joy
and imperials of sadness my son likes to
joke that
i have a song for every sentence he will
say because very often i will break into
a song with a sentence he'll say
my wife calls me the radio because i i
can sort of recite hundreds of songs
uh that have really shaped me so it's
very it's gonna be very hard to just
pick a few so i'm just gonna tell you a
little bit about my
song transition as i've grown up in
greece it was
very much about as i told you before the
misery
the poverty but also a very calming
adversity
so some of the songs that i that have
really shaped me
are uh harry salixiu for example is one
of my favorite singers
uh in greece and then there's also
really just old traditional songs that
my parents used to
listen to like one of them is
which is basically oh if i was rich
and the song is painting this beautiful
picture
about all the noises that you hear in
the neighborhood in his poor
neighborhood
the train going by the priest walking to
the
church and the kids crying next door and
all of that
and he says with all of that i'm having
trouble falling asleep and dreaming
if i was rich and then it was like you
know
um break into that so it's this
juxtaposition
between the spirit and the sublime and
then the physical
and the harsh reality it's just not
having troubles
not not not being miserable so basically
rich to him just means
out of my misery basically
and then also being able to travel being
able to sort of be the captain of a ship
and you know see the world and stuff
like that so it's just such a beautiful
image so many of the greek songs just
like the poetry we talked about
they acknowledge the the cruelty the
difficulty of life but are longing for
a better life that's exactly right and
another one is the holy yeah
and this is one of those songs that has
like a fast and joyful
half and a slow and sad half and it goes
back and forth between them
and it's like
so poor you know basically uh it's the
state of being poor i don't i don't even
know if there's a word for that
in english and then fast parties
and then it's like oh you know um
basically
like the state of being poor and misery
uh you know for you
i write all my songs etc and then the
fast part is
in your arms grew up
and suffered and you know stood up
and you know rose
men with clear vision this whole concept
of
taking on the world with nothing to lose
because you've seen the worst of it
this imagery of silaki pariso pula
jarastakori
so it's describing the young men as
cypress trees
and that's probably one of my earliest
exposure to a metaphor to sort of
you know this very rich imagery and i
love about the fact that
i was reading a story to my kids the
other day and it was dark
and my daughter who's six is like oh can
i please see the pictures
and jonathan was eight so some of my
daughter
cleo uh is like oh let's look at the
pictures and my son jonathan he's like
but but cleo if you look at the pictures
it's just an image
if you just close your eyes and listen
it's a video
that's brilliant it's beautiful and he's
basically showing just
how much more the human imagination has
besides just a few images that
you know the book will give you and then
another one oh gosh this one is really
like
miserable it's it's called
perigali uh and it's basically
describing how
uh vigorously we took on our life
and we pushed hard towards the direction
that we then realized was the wrong one
and it again these songs give you so
much perspective there's no songs like
that in english that will basically you
know sort of just
smack you in the face about sort of the
passion and the force and the drive
and then it turns out ah we just
followed the wrong life
yeah and it's like wow
okay so that was you all right so that
that's like before 12. so so
you know growing up in sort of this
horrendously miserable you know sort of
view of romanticism of you know
suffering
so then my pre-teen years is like you
know learning english through songs
so basically you know listening to all
the american pop songs and then
memorizing them vocally before i even
knew what they meant
so you know madonna and michael jackson
and all of these sort of really popular
songs and you know george michael just
songs that i would just
listen to the radio and repeat vocally
and eventually as i started learning
english i was like oh wow
this thing i've been repeating i know i
now understand what it means without
re-listening to it
but just with re-repeating it was like
oh
again michael jackson's man in the
mirror is
uh teaching you that it's your
responsibility to just
improve yourself you know if you want to
make the world a better place take a
look at yourself and make the change
this whole concept of again i mean all
of these songs you can listen to them
shallowly or you can just listen to them
and say
oh there's deeper meaning here and i
think there's a certain philosophy
of of song as a way of touching the
psyche
so if you look at regions of the brain
people have lost their language ability
because they have an accident in that
region of the brain
can actually sing because it's exactly
the symmetric region
of the brain and that again teaches you
so much about language evolution
and sort of the the duality of
musicality and you know rhythmic
patterns and
eventually language do you have a sense
of why songs
developed so you're kind of suggesting
that it's possible that
there is something important about our
connection with song and with music on
the level of
the importance of language is it
possible it's not just possible in my
view
language comes after music language
comes after song
no seriously like basically my view of
human cognitive evolution
is rituals if you look at many early
cultures
there's rituals around every stage of
life
there's organized dance performances
around mating and if you look at mate
selection i mean that's an evolutionary
drive right there
so basically if you're not able to
string together a complex dance
as a bird you don't get a mate and that
actually forms
this development for many song
learning birds not every bird knows how
to sing
and not every bird knows how to learn a
complicated song
so basically there's birds that simply
have the same
few tunes that they know how to play and
a lot of that is inherent
and genetically encoded and others are
birds that learn
how to sing and the you know
if you look at a lot of these exotic
birds of paradise and stuff like that
like
the mating rituals they have are
enormously amazing
and i think human mating rituals of you
know ancient tribes
are not very far off from that and in my
view the sequential formation
of these movements is a prelude
to the cognitive capabilities that
ultimately enable language
and it's fascinating to think that
that's uh not just an accidental
precursor to intelligence
yeah it's uh sexually selected it's well
sexually selected
and it's a prerequisite yeah it's like
it's required for intelligence and and
even as language has now developed
i think the artistic expression is
needed like badly needed by our brain
so it's not just that oh our brain can
kind of
you know take a break and go do that
stuff no i mean you know
i don't know if you remember that scene
from oh gosh we're certain
technical movie in new hampshire uh
all all working no play make jackal dull
boy
boy uh the shining the shining
so there's this amazing scene where he's
constantly trying to
to concentrate and what what's coming
out of the typewriters is gibberish
and i have that image as well when i'm
when i'm working and i'm like
no basically all of this crazy you know
huge number of hobbies that i have
they're not just tolerated by my work
they're required by my work this ability
of sort of stretching your brain in all
these different directions
is connecting your emotional self and
your cognitive self
and that's a prerequisite to being able
to be cognitively
capable at least in my view yeah i
wonder if the world without art and
music
you're just making me realize that
perhaps that world would be
not just devoid of fun things to look at
or listen to but devoid of all the other
stuff all the
bridges and rockets and science exactly
exactly
creativity is not disconnected from art
and you know my kids
i mean you know i could be doing the
full math treatment to them no
they play the piano and they play the
violin and they play sports i mean
this whole you know sort of movement
and going through mazes and playing
tennis
and you know playing soccer and avoiding
obstacles
and all of that that forms your
three-dimensional view of the world
being able to actually move and run and
play in three dimensions
is extremely important for math for you
know stringing together complicated
concepts
it's the same underlying cognitive
machinery
that is used for navigating mazes and
for
navigating theorems and sort of solving
equations so
i can't you know i can't have a
conversation with my students without
you know sort of either using my hands
or
opening the white board in zoom and just
constantly drawing
or you know back when we had in-person
meetings just the whiteboard in my
lifeboard yeah that that's fascinating
to think about uh so
that's michael jackson man amir careless
whisper
george michael which is the song i like
whisper i mean
i didn't say that i like that one that's
me i had two parties
i had recorded no no that it's an
amazing song for me
i had recorded a small part of it as it
played at the tail end of the radio
and i had a tape where i only had part
of that song
over and over and over again just so
beautiful
it's so heartbreaking that song is
almost greek it's so heartbreaking i
know
george michael he's greek is he great
he's greek he's known george michael
he's right i mean he's greedy yeah
you know so sorry to offend you so
deeply not knowing this
so okay so anyway so we're moving to
france when i'm 12 years old and now i'm
getting into the songs of gansburg
so gansburg is this incredible french
composer
he is always seen on stage like not even
pretending to
try to please just like with his
cigarette just like mumbling his songs
but the lyrics are unbelievable like
basically
entire sentences will rhyme he will say
the same thing twice
and you're like whoa
and in fact another speaking of greek a
french greek
george mustachy this song is just
magnificent
avec magulo demetec de chief eran de
patragrec
so with my face of
metec is actually a greek word it's uh
you know it's a french word for a greek
word
but met mean comes from meta and then ek
from ikea from ecology which means home
so medtech is someone who has changed
homes for a migrant
so with my face of a migrant and and
you'll love this one
the juice the patrick of a
meandering jew of greek
pastor so again you know the russian
greek
you know jew orthodox connection so
emesis with my hair in the four wings
avec mesut de la vega
with my eyes that are all washed out who
gives me the pretense of dreaming but
who don't dream
that much anymore with my hands of
thief of musician and
who have stolen so many gardens with my
mouth
that has drunk that has kissed
and that has bitten without ever
pleasing its hunger
with my skin
that has been rubbed in the sun of all
the summers
and anything that was wearing a skirt
with my heart and then you have to
listen to this first it's so beautiful
fair with my heart
that knew how to make suffer as much as
it suffered
but was able to that knew how to make
in french is actually fair that knew how
to
make yes
verses that span the whole thing it's
just beautiful you know
yeah on a small tangent do you know jack
jacques
bro of course of course
that song gets me every time so there's
a
cover of that song by one of my favorite
female artists
not nina simone no no no no modern carol
emerald
she's um from amsterdam and
uh she she has a version of new mexico
where she's actually added some english
lyrics and it's it's really beautiful
but again the mekita pai is just so
i mean it's you know the promises yeah
the volcanoes that you know will restart
yeah it's just so beautiful and uh i
love so
there's not many songs that so
sh shows such depth of desperation for
another human being that that's so
powerful
and then high school now i'm starting to
learn english so i moved to new york
so stings englishman in new york yeah
magnificent song and again there's
if manners magus man has someone said
then he's the hero of the day it takes a
man to suffer ignorance and smile
be yourself no matter what they say
and then takes more than combat gear to
make a man
takes more than a license for a gun
confront your enemies
avoid them when you can a gentleman will
walk but never run
it's it again you're talking about songs
that teach you how to live
i mean this is one of them basically
says it's not the combat gear that makes
a man
where's the part where he says uh there
you go
gentle uh gentleness sobriety a rare in
this society
at night a candle is brighter than the
sun
so beautiful he basically says well you
just might be the only one
modesty propriety can lead to notoriety
you could end up as the only one
it's um it basically tells you you don't
have to be like the others
be yourself show kindness show
generosity
don't you know don't let that anger get
to you
you know the song fragile how fragile we
are
how fragile we are so again as in greece
i didn't even know what that meant how
fragile we are but
the song was so beautiful and then
eventually i learned english and i
actually understand the lyrics and the
song is actually written
after the contras murdered ben linder in
1987
and the us eventually turned against
supporting
these guerrillas and it was just a
political song but so such a realization
that
you can't win with violence basically
and that song starts with the most
beautiful poetry so
if blood will flow when flesh and steel
are won
drying in the color of the evening sun
tomorrow's rain will wash the stains
away
but something in our minds will always
stay
perhaps this final act was meant to
clinch a lifetime's argument
that nothing comes from violence and
nothing ever could
for all those born beneath an angry star
lest we forget how fragile we are
damn right i mean that's poetry
it was beautiful and he's using the
english language in just such a
refined way with deep meanings
but also words that rhyme just so
beautifully
and evocations of when flesh and steel
are won
i mean it's just mind-boggling yeah and
then of course
the refrain that everybody remembers is
on and on the rain will fall
etc but like this beginning yeah
and again tears from a star how fragile
we are
i mean just these rhymes are just
flowing so naturally this something
it's it seems that more meaning comes
when there's a rhythm
that uh i don't know what what that is
that probably connects to
exactly what you're saying if you pay
close attention you will notice that
the more obvious words sometimes are the
second
verse and the less obvious are often the
first verse
because it makes the second verse flow
much more naturally
because otherwise it feels contrived oh
you went and found this like unusual
word yes
in dark moments uh the whole album of
pink floyd
and the movie just marked me enormously
yeah as a
as a teenager just the wall um and
there's one song that never actually
made it into the album that's only there
in the movie
about when the tigers broke free and the
tigers are the tanks
of the germans and it just describes
again this
vivid imagery it was just before dawn
one miserable morning
in black 44 when the forward commander
was told to sit tight
when he asked that his men be withdrawn
and the generals gave thanks
as the other ranks held back the enemy
tanks
for a while and the ancient
bridgehead was held for the price of a
few
hundred ordinary lives so that's a theme
that keeps coming back in pink floyd
with us versus them
us and them god only knows that's not
what we would choose
to do forward he cried
from the rear and the front rows died
from another song it's like this whole
concept of
us versus them and there's that theme of
us versus them again
where the child is discovering how his
father died
when he finds an old and founded one day
in a draw the whole photographs hidden
away
and my eyes still grow damp to remember
his
majesty signed with his own rubber stamp
so it's so ironic because it seems the
way that he's writing it that he's not
crying because his father was lost
he's crying because kind old king george
took the time to actually write mother a
note about the fact that his father died
it's so ironic because he basically says
we are just ordinary men and of course
we're disposable
so i don't know if you know the root of
the word pioneers
but you had a chess board here earlier a
pawn
in france is a pyong they are the ones
that you send to the front to get
murdered slaughter
this whole concept of pioneers having
taken these whole disposable ordinary
men
to actually be the ones that you know
we're now treating as heroes
so anyway there's this just supposition
of that and then the part that always
just
strikes me is the music and the tonality
totally changes
and now he describes the attack it was
dark all around
there was frost in the ground when the
tigers broke free
and no one survived from the royal
fusiliers company z
they were all left behind most of them
dead the rest of them dying
and that's how the high command took my
daddy from me and that song even though
it's not in the album
explains the whole movie because it's
this movie of
misery it's this movie of someone being
stuck in their head
and not being able to get out of it
there's no other movie that i think has
captured so well
this prison that is someone's own mind
and this wall that you're stuck inside
in this
you know feeling of loneliness and so
if is there anybody out there uh
and you know sort of hello hello is
there anybody in there
just not if you can hear me is there
anyone who
anyway so yeah the prison of your mind
so those are the darker moments
exactly these are the darker moments
yeah it's in the darker moments the mind
does feel
like you're you're trapped in alone in a
room
with it yeah and there's this this scene
in the movie which
like where he just breaks out with his
guitar and there's this prostitute in
the room he starts throwing stuff and
then he like
you know breaks the window he throws the
chair outside and then you see him
laying in the pool
with his own blood like you know
everywhere and then
there's these endless hours spent fixing
every little thing and lining it up
and it's this whole sort of mania versus
you know
you can spend hours building up
something and just destroy it in a few
seconds
one of my turns is that song and it's
like
i feel cold as eternity
dry as a funeral drum and then the music
people
are saying run to the bedroom there's a
suitcase on the left
you'll find my favorite axe
don't look so frightened this is just a
passing phase
one of my bad days it's just so
beautiful
i need to rewatch it that's so yeah but
imagine you're watching this as a
teenager
it like ruins your mind
like so many such harsh imagery
and then um you know anyway so so
there's the dark moment and then again
going back to sting
now it's the political songs russians
and i think that song
should be a a new national anthem for
the u.s not for russians but for red
versus
blue mr khrushchev says we will bury you
i don't subscribe to this point of view
it'd be such an ignorant thing to do
if the russians love their children
too what is it doing it's basically
saying
the russians are just as humans as we
are
there's no way that they're going to let
their children die
and then it's just so beautiful how can
i
save my innocent boy from oppenheimer's
deadly toy and now that's the new
national anthem are you reading
there isn't no monopoly of common sense
on
either side of the political fence
we share the same biology
regardless of ideology
believe me when i say to you
i hope the russians love their children
too
there's no such thing as a winnable war
it's a lie we don't believe anymore
i mean it's beautiful right and for
god's sake america wake up
these are your fellow americans they're
your your
fellow biology you know there is no
monopoly of common sense on either side
of the political fans it's just so
beautiful
there's no crisper simpler way to say
russians love their children too
the the common humanity yeah and
remember the
what i was telling you i think in one of
her first podcasts about
the the daughter who's crying for her
husband from for her brother to come
back for more
and then the virgin mary appears and
says who should i take instead
this turk here's his family here's his
children this other
one he just got married etc
and that basically says no i mean if you
look at the lord of the rings
the enemies are these monsters they're
not human
and that's what we always do we always
say they
you know they're not like us they're
different they're not humans etc
so there's this dehumanization that has
to happen for people to go to war
you know if you realize just how close
we are genetically one with the other
this whole 99.9 identical
you can't bear weapons against someone
who's like that
and the things that are the most
meaningful to us in our life lies
at every level is the same on all sides
on both sides
exactly so not just that we're
genetically the same yeah
we're ideologically the same we love our
children we love our country we will
you know we will fight for our family
yeah so and the last one i mentioned
last time we spoke which is johnny
mitchell's
both sides now so she
she has three rounds one on clouds one
on love and one on life
and on cloud she says rose and flows of
angel
hair and ice cream castles in the
air and feather canyons everywhere
have looked at clouds that way but now
they only block the sun they rain and
snow
on everyone so many things i would have
done
but clouds got in my way and then i've
looked at clouds from both sides now
from
up and down and still somehow it's
clouds illusions i recall i
really don't know clouds
at all and then she goes on about love
how it's
super super happy or it's about misery
and loss and about life
how it's about winning and losing and so
so forth
but now old friends are acting strange
they shake their heads they say i've
changed
well some things lost since something's
gained
and living every day so again that's
growing up and realizing that well
the view that you had as a kid is not
necessarily that you have as an adult
i remember my poem from when i was 16
years old of this whole
you know children dance now all in row
and then in the end
even though the snow seems bright
without you have lost their light sound
that sang and moon that smiled
so this whole concept of if you have
love
and if you have passion you see the
exact same thing from a different way
you can go out running in the rain or
you could just stay in and say ah
sucks i won't be able to go outside now
both sides
anyway and the last one is last last one
from
leonard cohen this is amazing by the way
you're
i'm so glad we stumbled on how much how
much
joy you have in so many avenues of life
and music is just one of them that's
amazing but yes leno cohen
going back to the undercover and since
that's where you started so uh leonard
cohen's danced me to the end of love
that's what
that was our opening song in our wedding
with my wife oh no
that's what came out to greet the guest
he was dancing to the end of love
and then another one which is just so
passionate always and we always keep
referring back to it is uh i'm your man
and it goes on and on about sort of i
can be every type of lover for you
and what's really beautiful in marriage
is that we live that with my
with my wife every day you can have the
passion
you can have the anger you can have the
love you can have the tenderness
there's just so many gems in that song
if you want a partner
take my hand or if you want to strike me
down in anger here i stand
i'm your man then if you want a boxer
i will step into the ring for you if you
want a driver
climb inside or if you want to take me
for a ride
you know you can so this whole concept
of you want to drive
i'll follow you want me to drive i'll
drive
um and the difference i would say
between like that and namaki to paw
is this song he's got an attitude he's
like
uh he's proud of this his ability to
basically be any kind of man for the
money
as opposed to the jacques brown like
desperation of what do i have to be for
you to love me that kind of desperation
but but but notice there's a parallel
here there's a verse
that is perhaps not paid attention to as
much which says
ah but a man never got a woman back
not by begging on his knees
so it seems that the amber man is
actually an apology song
in the same way that number kitty pie is
an apology song
i'm sorry baby and in the same way that
the careless whisper
is now screwed up yes that's right i'm
never gonna dance again
guilty feet have got no rhythm
um so so this is an apology song not by
begging on his knees or i'd crawl to you
baby and i'd fall at your
feet and not howl at your beauty like a
dog
heat and i'd close at your heart not
tear
at your sheet i'd say please
and then the the last one is so
beautiful
if you want a father for your child
or only one to walk with me a while
across the sand
i'm your man that's the the last
verses which basically says you want me
for a day
i'll be there do you want me to walk
i'll be there you want me for
life if you want a father for your child
i'll be there too
it's just so beautiful oh sorry remember
i told you i was going to finish with a
lighthearted song yes
ah last one you ready so yeah
alison krause and union station country
song believe it or not
the lucky one so
i i've never identified as much with
the uh lyrics of a song
as this one and it's hilarious my friend
serving patoglo
is the guy who got me to genomics in the
first place i owe
enormously to him and he's another greek
we actually met dancing believe or not
so we used to perform greek dances
uh i was the president of the
international students association so we
put on these
big performances for 500 people at mit
and
uh there's a picture on the mit tech
where seraphim who's like you know
bodybuilder was holding on his shoulder
and i was like like doing maneuvers in
the air basically um
so anyway this guy seraphim um we were
driving back from
um a conference and there's this russian
girl who was describing how every member
of her family had been either
killed by the communists or killed by
the germans were killed
like she had just like you know misery
like
death and you know sickness and
everything everyone was decimated in her
family she was the last standing member
and we stopped at a the serpent was
driving and we stopped at a
at a rest area and he he takes me aside
and he's like manolis
we're gonna crash get her out of my car
and then he basically says but but but
i'm only reassured because you're here
with me
and i'm like what do you mean he's like
he you know he's like from your smile
i know you're the luckiest man on the
planet
so there's this really funny thing where
i just
feel freaking lucky all the time and
it's an it's a question of attitude of
course i'm not any luckier than any
other person but if it's science
something horrible happens to me i'm
like and in fact even in that song the
the song about sort of you know walking
on the beach and this
you know sort of taking our life the
wrong way and then you know
having to turn around at some point he's
like you know
in the fresh sand we wrote her name
aurea buffy so bad so shows how nicely
that the wind blew
and the writing was erased so again it's
this whole sort of
not just saying ah bummer but
oh great i just lost this this must mean
something
right horrible thing happened it must
open uh
that's the door turns and you do a
beautiful chapter so so alison krause
is talking about the lucky one so i was
like oh my god she wrote a song for me
and she goes you're the lucky one i know
that now
as free as the wind blowing down the
road loved by many hated by none i'd say
you were lucky cause you know what
you've done not the care in the world
not the
worrying side everything's gonna be all
right cause you're the lucky one
and then she goes uh you're the lucky
one always having fun a jack of all
trades a master of none
you look at the world with the smiling
eyes and laugh at the devil as his train
rolls by
i'll give you a song and a one-night
stand you'll be looking at the
happy man because you're the lucky one
it basically says
if you just don't worry too much if you
don't try to be
you know a one hor a one-trick pony if
you just
embrace the fact that you might suck at
a bunch of things
but you're just gonna try a lot of
things and then there's another verse
that says well you're blessed i guess
but never knowing which road you're
choosing
to you the next best thing to playing
and winning is playing and losing
it's just so beautiful because it
basically says
if you try
your best but it's still playing
if you lose it's okay you had an awesome
game
and um again superficially it sounds
like a super happy song
but then there's a the last verse
basically says
no matter where you are that's where
you'll be you can bet your luck won't
follow me
just give you a song and then one night
stand you'll be looking at a happy man
and in the video of the song she just
walks away or he just walks away or
something like that
and it basically tells you that freedom
comes at a price
freedom comes at the price of
non-commitment this whole sort of
vertical love of births will cry
you can't really love unless you cry you
can't just be the lucky one the happy
boy
and yet have a long-term relationship
so it's you know on one hand i identify
with the shallowness of this song
of you know you're the lucky one jack of
all trades or master none
but at the same time i identify with a
lesson of
well you can't just be the happy mary go
lucky all the time
sometimes you have to embrace loss and
sometimes you have to embrace suffering
and sometimes you have to embrace that
if you have a safety net you're not
really committing enough
you're not you know basically you're
allowing yourself to slip
but if you just go all in and you just
you know
let go of your reservations that's when
you truly will get somewhere
so anyway that's like the the i managed
to narrow it down to what
15 songs thank you for that wonderful
journey
that you just took us on the the the the
darkest possible places of
greek song to uh to ending in this a
country song
i haven't heard it before but uh that's
exactly right i feel the same way
depending depending on the day is this
the luckiest human on earth
and there's some there's something to
that but you're right it
it needs to be we need to now return to
the muck
of life in order to be able to
to uh to truly enjoy it so that's what
you mean
muck what's muck uh the messiness of
life
the things the word things don't
turn out the way you expect it to yeah
the way so like to feel
lucky is like focusing on the on the
beautiful consequences yeah
but then that feeling of things being
different
than you expected that uh you stumble in
all the kinds of ways that
that seems to be needs to be paired with
the feeling there's basically one way
the only way not to make mistakes is to
never do anything
right basically you have to embrace the
fact that you'll be wrong
so many times in so many research
meetings i just go off on a tangent and
say let's think about this for a second
and it's just
crazy for me who's a computer scientist
to just
tell my biologist friends what if
biology kind of worked this way
and they humor me they just let me talk
and
rarely has it not gone somewhere good
it's not that i'm always right but it's
always something worth exploring further
that if you're an outsider with humility
and knowing that i'll be wrong a bunch
of times
but i'll challenge your assumptions
you know and often take us to a better
place is
part of this whole sort of messiness of
life like if you don't try
and lose and get hurt and suffer and cry
and just break your heart and all these
feelings of guilt and
you know wow i did the wrong thing of
course that's part of life and that's
just something that
you know if you are the a doer
you'll make mistakes if you're a
criticizer
yeah sure you can still sit back and
criticize everybody else for the
mistakes they make
or instead you can just be out there
making those mistakes and frankly i'd
rather be the criticized one than the
criticizer
brilliantly put every time somebody
steals my bicycle i say well
i know my son is like why do they steal
our bicycle that and i'm like
aren't aren't you happy that you have
bicycles that people can steal
i'd rather be the person stolen from
than the steeler yeah
not the critic that counts yeah so
that's
we've just talked amazingly about life
from the music perspective
let's uh talk about life from human life
from perhaps other perspective and it's
meaning
so this is episode 142.
uh there is perhaps uh an
absurdly uh deep
meaning to the number 42 that uh
the our culture has has elevated so this
is a perfect time to talk about the
meaning of life
we've talked about it already but do you
think this question
that's so simple and
so seemingly absurd has value
of what is the meaning of life is it
something
that raising the question and trying to
answer it
is that a ridiculous pursuit or is this
some value is it answerable at all
so first of all i i feel that we owe it
to your listeners to say why 42
sure so of course the hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy
came up with 42 as basically a random
number just you know the author just
pulled it out of a hat
and he's admitted so he said mile 42
just seemed like
just random numbers any but in fact
there's many
numbers that are linked to 42. so
42 again just just to summarize
is the answer that these
super mega computer that had computed
for a million years
with the most powerful computer in the
world had come up with at some point
the computer says um i have an answer
and they're like what it's like you're
not going to like it
like what is it it's 42.
and then the irony is that they had
forgotten of course what the question
was yes
so now they have to build a bigger
computer to figure out what the question
was the question
to which the answer is 42. so as i was
turning 42
i basically sort of researched uh why 42
is such a cool number
and it turns out that and i put together
this little passage that was explaining
to all those
guests to my 42nd birthday party why we
were talking about the meaning of life
and basically talked about how 42
is the angle at which light reflects
off of water to create a rainbow
and it's so beautiful because the
rainbow is basically the
combination of sort of it's been raining
but there's hope because the sun just
came out
it's a very beautiful number there so 42
is also the sum
of all rows and columns of a magic cube
that contains
all consecutive integers starting at one
so basically if you if you take all
integers between one
and however many vertices there are the
sums is always 42.
42 is the only number
left under 100 for which the equation of
x to the cube
plus y to the q plus z to the cube is n
and was not known to not have a solution
and now
it's the you know it's the only one that
actually has a solution 42 is also
1 0 1 0 1 0 in binary again the yin and
the yang the good and the evil
one and zero the balance of the force 42
is the number of chromosomes for the
giant panda
and the giant panda i know it's totally
random
or a suspicious symbol of great strength
coupled with peace
friendship gentle temperament harmony
balance and friendship
whose black and white colors again
symbolize yin and yang the reason why
it's the symbol for
china is exactly the strength but yet
peace
and so forth so 42 chromosomes it takes
light
10 to the minus 42 seconds to cross the
diameter of a proton
connecting the two fundamental
dimensions of space and time
42 is the number of times a piece of
paper should be folded
to reach beyond the moon
so um which is what i
assume my students mean when they ask
that their paper reaches for the stars i
just tell them just fold it a bunch of
times
42 is the number of messier object 42
which is
orion and that's you know one of the
most
famous galaxies it's i think also the
place where
we can actually see the center of our
galaxy uh 42 is the numeric
representation of the star symbol
in ascii which is very useful when
searching for the stars
yeah and also a regex for life the
universe and everything
so star in egyptian mythology
the goddess ma'at which was personifying
truth and justice
would ask 42 questions to every dying
person
and those answering successfully would
become stars continue to give life and
fuel universal growth
in judaic tradition goddess scribe is
ascribed a 42-lettered name
entrusted only to the middle age pius
meek free from bad temper
sober and not insistent on his rights
and in christian tradition there's 42
generations from abraham
isaac that we talked about the story of
isaac jacob
eventually joseph mary and jesus in
kabbalistic tradition
eloka which is 42 is the number with
which god creates the universe
starting with 25 letter b and ending
with 17
good so 25 plus you know
17. there's this 42 chapter sutra
which is the first indian religious
scripture which was translated to
chinese
thus introducing buddhism to china from
india
the 42 line bible was the first printed
book making the
mark marking the age of printing in the
1450s and the dissemination of knowledge
eventually leading to the enlightenment
a yeast cell
which is uh called a single cell
eukaryote and the subject of my phd
research has
exactly 42 million proteins anyway so
so there's seriously you're on fire with
this these are really good
so i guess what you're saying is just a
random number yeah basically
so all of these are acronyms so you know
after you have the number you figure out
why that don't work
so anyway so uh now that we've spoken
about why 42
uh why do we search for meaning and uh
you're asking you know will that search
ultimately lead to our destruction and
my my thinking is exactly the opposite
so basically
that asking about meaning is something
that's so
inherent to human nature it's something
that makes life beautiful
that makes it worth living and that
searching for meaning
is actually the point it's not defining
it i think when you found it you're dead
yeah don't don't ever be satisfied that
you know i've got it so i like to say
that life is
lived forward but it only makes sense
backward
and i don't remember whose quote that is
but
the the the whole search itself is the
meaning
and what i love about it is that
there's a double search going on there's
a search in
every one of us through our own lives to
find meaning
and then there's a search which is
happening for humanity itself
to find our meaning and
we as humans like to look at animals and
say of course they have a meaning
like a dog has its meaning it's just a
bunch of instincts
you know running around loving
everything um
you know remember a joke with a cat in
the dark
no no so so um and
i i'm noticing the yin yang symbol right
here with this whole panda
black and white and the zero one zero
one five with that 42. some of those are
gold
ascii value for uh the star symbol
damn anyway so so basically in my view
the
the search for meaning and the act of
uh searching for something more
meaningful
is life's meaning
by itself but the fact that we kind of
always hope that yes maybe for animals
that's not the case
but maybe humans have something that we
should be doing
and something else and it's not just
about procreation it's not just about
dominance it's not just about strength
and feeding et cetera
like we're the one species that spends
such a tiny little minority of its time
feeding that we have this enormous
you know huge cognitive capability
that we can just use for all kinds of
other stuff and that's where art
comes in that's where you know the
healthy mind
comes in with you know exploring all of
these different aspects that are just
not
directly tied to um
to a purpose that's not directly tied to
a function it's really just the the
playing
of life the you know not not for
particular reason do you think this
thing we got
this this mind is unique in the universe
in terms of how difficult it is to build
so
is it possible that we're the the most
beautiful thing that the universe has
constructed both the most beautiful the
most ugly but certainly the most complex
so look at evolutionary time uh the
dinosaurs ruled the earth for 135
million years
we've been around for a million years
so one versus 135. so
dinosaurs were extinct you know about 60
million years ago and mammals that had
been happily evolving as tiny little
creatures
for 30 million years then took over the
planet and then you know dramatically
radiated about 60 million years ago
out of these mammals came the neocortex
formation so basically the the neocortex
which is sort of the outer layer of our
brain
compared to our quote-unquote reptilian
brain which we share the structure of
with all of the dinosaurs they didn't
have that and yet they ruled the planet
so how many other planets
have still you know mindless dinosaurs
where strength was the only dimension uh
ruling the planet
so there was something weird that
annihilated the dinosaurs
and again you could look at biblical
things of sort of god coming and wiping
out his creatures and yes to make room
for the next ones
so the mammals basically sort of took
off the planet and then grew
this cognitive capability of this
general-purpose machine and primates
push that to extreme and humans among
primates
have just exploded that hardware
but that hardware is selected
for survival it's selected for
procreation
it's initially selected with this very
simple darwinian view of the world
of random mutation ruthless selection
and then selection for making more of
yourself
if you look at human cognition
it's gone down a weird evolutionary path
in the sense that
we are expending an enormous amount of
energy on this
apparatus between our ears that is
wasting what 15
of our bodily energy 20 like some
enormous
percentage of our calories
go to function our brain
no other species makes that big of a
commitment
that has basically taken energetic
changes for efficiency on the metabolic
side
for humanity to basically power that
thing
and our brain is both enormously more
efficient than other brains
but also despite this efficiency
enormously more energy consuming
so and if you look at just the sheer
folds
that the human brain has again our skull
could only
grow so much before it could no longer
go through the pelvic
opening and kill the mother
at every birth so but yet the fault
continued
effectively creating just so much more
capacity
the evolutionary uh context in which
this was made
is enormously fascinating and it has to
do with
other humans that we have now killed off
or that have gone extinct
and that has now created this weird
place of humans
on the planet as the only species that
has this enormous hardware
so that can basically make us think that
there's something very weird and unique
that happened in human evolution that
perhaps has not been recreated elsewhere
maybe the asteroid didn't hit
you know sister earth and the dinosaurs
are still ruling
and you know any any kind of proto-human
is squished and
eaten for breakfast basically
however we're not as unique as we like
to think
because there was this enormous
diversity of other human-like forms
and once you make it to that stage where
you have a neocortex-like
explosion of wow we're now competing on
intelligence
and we're now competing on social
structures and we're now competing on
larger and larger groups and being able
to
coordinate and being able to have
empathy
the concept of empathy the concept of an
ego
the concept of a self of self-awareness
comes probably from being able to
project another person's intentions
to understand what they mean when you
have these large
cognitive groups large social groups so
me being able to sort of create a mental
model of how you think
may have come before i was able to
create a personal
mental model of how do i think so this
introspection
probably came after this sort of
projection and this empathy which
basically means
you know passion pathos suffering
but basically sensing so basically
empathy means
feeling what you're feeling trying to
project your emotional state
onto my cognitive apparatus and i think
that
is what eventually led to
this enormous cognitive explosion that
happened in humanity
so you know life itself
in my view is inevitable on every planet
inevitable inevitable but the evolution
of life
to self-awareness and cognition and all
the incredible things that humans have
done
you know that might not be as inevitable
that's your intuition so
uh if you were to sort of uh estimate
and bet some money on it
if we re-ran earth a million times
would what we got now be the most
special thing
and how often would it be so
scientifically speaking
how repeatable is this experiment
so this whole cognitive revolution yes
maybe not maybe not basically i feel
that
the longevity of you know dinosaurs
suggests that it was not quite
inevitable that we uh
that we humans eventually uh made it
what you're also implying one thing here
you're saying
you're implying that humans also don't
have this longevity
this is the interesting question so with
the fermi paradox
the idea that the basic question is like
if if the universe has a lot of uh alien
life forms in it why haven't we seen
them
yeah and one thought is that there is a
great filter or multiple great filters
that basically would destroy intelligent
civilizations like we
this thing that we you know this
multi-folding brain
that can keeps growing may not be such a
big feature
it might be useful for survival but it
like
takes us down a uh side road
that is a very short one with a quick
dead end what do you think about that
so i think the universe is enormous
not just in space but also in time
and the the pretense that
you know the last blink of an instant
that we've been able to send radio waves
is when somebody should have been paying
attention to our planet
he's a little ridiculous so my
you know what i love about star wars yes
is
a long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away it's not like some distant future
it's a long long time ago
what i love about it is that basically
says you know evolution
and civilization are just so recent
in you know on earth like there's
countless other planets that have
probably all kinds of life forms
multicellular perhaps
and so forth but
the fact that humanity has only been
listening and
emitting for just this tiny little blink
means that any of these you know alien
civilizations would need to be paying
attention to
every single insignificant planet out
there and
you know again i mean the movie contact
and the book is just so beautiful this
whole concept of
we don't need to travel physically we
can travel as light
we can send instructions for people to
create machines
that will allow us to beam down light
and recreate ourselves
and in the book you know the aliens
actually take over
they're not as friendly but you know
this concept that
we have to eventually go and conquer
every planet i mean i think that
yes we will become a galactic species so
you you have um
hope well you said thanks oh of course
of course i mean
now that we've made it so far you we so
you think i
made it oh gosh i feel that you know
cognition
the cognition as an evolutionary trait
has won over in our planet
there's no doubt that we've made it so
basically humans have
won the battle for you know uh dominance
it wasn't necessarily the case with
dinosaurs like i mean
yes you know there's some claims of
uh intelligence and if you look at
jurassic park yeah sure whatever
but you know they just don't have the
hardware for it
yeah and humans have the hardware
there's no doubt that mammals
have a dramatically improved hardware
for cognition
over dinosaurs like basically there's
universes where
strength went out and in our planet in
our
you know particular version of whatever
happened in this planet
cognition went out and it's kind of cool
i mean it's it's a privilege
right but it's kind of like living in
boston instead of i don't know
some middle uh middle-aged uh
place where everybody's like hitting
each other with with uh you know some
weapons and sticks back to the lucky one
song
i mean we are the lucky ones but the
flip side of that
uh is that this hardware also allows us
to develop
weapons and methods of destroying
ourselves
so you again i want to go back to pinker
yeah and the better angels of our nature
the whole concept that
civilization and the act of civilizing
has dramatically reduced violence
dramatically if you look you know
at every scale as soon as
organization comes the state basically
owns the right to violence and
eventually
the state gives that right of
governance to the people but but
violence has been eliminated by that
state
so this whole concept of central
governance
and people agreeing to live together and
share responsibilities and duties
and you know all of that is something
that has led
so much to less violence less death
less suffering less you know poverty
less um you know war i mean
yes we have the capability to destroy
ourselves
but the arc of civilization has led to
much much less destruction much much
less war and much more peace
and of course there's blips back and
forth
and you know there are setbacks but
again
the moral arc of the universe but it
seems to just i probably imagine there
were two dinosaurs back in the day
having this exact conversation
and they look up to the sky and there
seems to be something like an asteroid
going towards earth so it's while it's
it's very true
that the the arc of our society of human
civilization
seems to be progressing towards a better
better life for everybody
in in the many ways that you described
uh things can change in a moment
and it feels like it's not just us
humans we're living through a pandemic
you could imagine that a pandemic would
be more destructive or
or there could be asteroids that just
appear out of the the darkness of space
which i would recently learned it's not
that easy to uh
give you another number detect them yes
so 48
what happens in 48 years
2068 apophis there's an asteroid that's
coming
in 48 years it has very high chance of
actually wiping us out
completely yes so we have 48
48 years to get our act together it's
not like some distant distant
hypothesis yes like yeah sure they're
hard to detect but this one we know
about it's coming
so how do you feel about that why are
you still talking oh gosh i'm so happy
with where we are now this is going to
be great seriously if you look at
progress
if you look at again the speed with
which
knowledge has been transferred what what
has
led to humanity making so many advances
so fast
okay so what has led to humanity
making so many advances is not just the
hardware upgrades
it's also the software upgrades so by
hardware upgrades i basically mean our
neocortex
and the expansion and these layers and
you know folds of her brain
and all of that that's the hardware the
software
hasn't uh you know the the hardware
hasn't changed much
in the last what seventy thousand years
as i mentioned last time if you take a
person from ancient egypt and you bring
them up now
they're just as equally fit so
hardware hasn't changed what has changed
is software
what has changed is that we
are growing up in societies that are
much more complex
this whole concept of neotimi basically
allows our exponential growth
the concept that our brain has not fully
formed has not fully
stabilized itself until after teenage
years so we basically have a good 16
years 18 years
to sort of infuse it with the latest and
greatest in software
if you look at what happened in ancient
greece why
did everything explode at once my take
on this
is that it was the shift from the
egyptian and hieroglyphic software
to the greek language software
this whole concept of creating abstract
notions
of creating these um
layers of cognition
and layers of meaning and layers of
abstraction for
words and ideals and beauty and
harmony how do you write harmony in
hieroglyphics there's no such thing as
you know sort of expressing these ideals
of
peace and justice and you know these
concepts of
or even you know uh macabre concepts
of doom etc like you don't you don't
have the language for it
your brain has trouble
getting at that concept
so what i'm trying to say is that these
software upgrades
for human language human culture
human environment human education have
basically led to this enormous explosion
of knowledge and eventually after the
enlightenment
and as i was mentioning the 42 line
bible
and the printed press the dissemination
of knowledge you basically now have this
whole horizontal
dispersion of ideas in addition to the
vertical
inheritance of genes so the hardware
improvements happen through vertical
inheritance the software improvements
happen
through horizontal inheritance and the
reason why human civilization exploded
is not a hardware change anymore it's
really a software change
so if you're looking at now where we are
today
look at coronavirus yes sure it could
have killed us
a hundred years ago it would have but it
didn't
why because in january we
we published the genome a month later
less than a month later the first
vaccine designs were done
and now less than a year later 10 months
later
we already have a working vaccine that's
90 efficient i mean that is ridiculous
by
any standards and the reason is sharing
so you know the asteroid yes could wipe
us out in 48 years but 48 years
i mean look at where we were 48 years
ago
technologically i mean how much more we
understand
the basic foundations of space
is enormous the technological
revolutions of
digitization the amount of compute power
we can put on any like
you know by in nail size
you know hardware is enormous so and
this
is nowhere near ending you know we all
have our like little
you know problems going back and forth
on the social side yeah and on the
political side on the cognitive
and on the sort of human side and the
societal side
but science has not slowed down
science is moving at a breakneck pace
ahead
so you know elon is now putting rockets
out
from the private space i mean that now
democratization
of space exploration is you know gonna
reveal it's gonna explode
continue in the same way that every
technology has exploded
this is the shift to space technology
exploding
so 48 years is infinity from now
in terms of space capabilities so i'm
not worried at all
are you excited by the possibility of a
human
well one human stepping foot on mars and
to possible colonization of not
necessarily mars but other planets and
all that kind of stuff for people living
in space
inevitable and never inevitable would
you do it are you kind of like earth
you know how many how many how many
people will you wait when you wait for
i think it was about when um the the
declaration of
independence was signs about two to
three million people lived
here so would you move like before would
you be like
on the first boat would you be on the
10th boat would you wait until the
declaration of independence
i don't think i'll be on the shortlist
because i'll be old by then
they'll probably get a bunch of younger
people but you're it's the
it's the wisdom and the uh the wait
then you are in the classroom
horizontally you i gotta tell you you
are the lucky one so you might be on the
list i don't know
yeah i mean i i kind of feel like i
would love to see
earth from above just to watch our
planet
i mean just i mean you know you can
watch a live feed of the
space station watching earth
is magnificent like this blue tiny
little shield
it's so thin our atmosphere like if you
drive to new york you're basically in
outer space i mean it's ridiculous it's
just so thin
and it's just again such a privilege to
be on this planet such a privilege
but i think our species is in for
big good things
i think that you know we will overcome
our little problems
and eventually come together as a
species i feel that we
we we're definitely on the path to that
and
you know it's just not permeated through
the whole
universe yeah i mean through the whole
world yet through the whole earth yet
but it's definitely permeating so you've
talked about humans as special
how exactly are we special relative to
the dinosaurs so i mentioned that
there's um you know this dramatic
cognitive
improvement that we've made but i think
it goes
much deeper than that so if you look at
a lion
attacking a gazelle in the middle of the
serengeti
the lion is smelling the molecules in
the environment
it's uh
hormones and neuroreceptors are sort of
getting it ready for impulse
the target is constantly looking around
and sensing
i've actually been in kenya and i've
kind of
seen the hunt yes i've kind of seen the
sort of game of waiting
and the mitochondria in the muscles
of the lion are basically ready for
you know jumping they're
expensing an enormous amount of energy
the grass as it's flowing
is constantly transforming solar energy
into chloroplasts you know through the
chloroplastin to
energy which eventually feeds the
gazelle and eventually feeds
the lions and so forth so as
humans we experience all of that
but the lion only experiences
one layer the mitochondria in its body
are only experiencing one layer the
chloroplasts are only experiencing one
layer
the you know photoreceptors and the
smell receptors the chemical receptors
like the lion always attacks against the
wind
so that it's not smelled like
all of these things are
one layer at a time and we humans
somehow perceive the whole stack
so going back to software infrastructure
and hardware infrastructure
if you design a computer you basically
have a physical layer
that you start with and then on top of
that physical layer you have
you know the electrical layer and on top
of the electrical layer you have
basically gates and logic and an
assembly layer
and on top of the assembly layer you
have your you know higher order
higher level programming and on top of
that you have your deep learning routine
etc
and on top of that you eventually build
a cognitive system
that's smart i want you to now picture
this cognitive system becoming not just
self-aware
but also becoming aware of the hardware
that it's made of
and the atoms that there that it's made
of and so forth
so it's as if your ai system and there's
this beautiful scene
in um 2001 odyssey of space
where where uh hull after dave starts
disconnecting him yes
he's starting to sing a song about
daisies etc
and hal is basically saying dave
i'm losing my mind i can feel
i'm losing my mind it's just so
beautiful
this concept of self-awareness of
knowing that the hardware is no longer
there is amazing
and in the same way humans who have had
accidents
are aware that they've had accidents so
there's this self-awareness of ai
that is you know this beautiful concept
about
you know sort of the eventual cognitive
leap
to self-awareness but imagine now the ai
system
actually breaking through these layers
and saying wait a minute i think i can
design a slightly better hardware
to get me functioning better and that's
what basically humans are doing
so if you if you look at our reasoning
layer it's built on top of a cognitive
layer
and the reasoning layer we share with ai
it's kind of cool
like there is another thing on the
planet that can integrate equations
and it's man-made but we share
computation with them
we share this cognitive layer of playing
chess we're not alone anymore
we're not the only thing on the planet
that plays chess now we have ai
that also plays chess but in some sense
that that particular organism ai as it
is now
only operates in that layer exactly
exactly
and then most animals operate in the
sort of
cognitive layer that we're all
experiencing a bat
is doing this incredible integration of
signals
but it's not aware of it it's basically
constantly
sending echo location
waves and it's receiving them back and
multiple bats in the same cave
are operating at slightly different
frequencies and with slightly different
pulses
and they're all sensing objects and
they're doing motion planning
in their cognitive hardware but they're
not even aware of all of that
all they know is that they have a 3d
view of space around them
just like any gazelle walking through
you know the desert
and any baby looking around
is aware of things without doing the
math of how am i processing
all of these visual information et
cetera you're just aware of the layer
that you live in
i think if you look at this
at humanity we've basically managed
through our cognitive layer
through our perception layer through our
senses layer through our
multi-organ layer through our genetic
layer
through our molecular layer through our
atomic layer through our quantum layer
through even the very fabric of the
space-time continuum
unite all of that cognitively so as
we're watching that scene in the
serengeti
we as scientists we as educated humans
we as
you know anyone who's finished high
school are aware of all of this
beauty of all of these different layers
interplaying together
and i think that's something very unique
in perhaps not just the galaxy but maybe
even the cosmos
this species that has managed to
in space cross through these layers from
the enormous to the infinitely small and
that's what i love about
particle physics the fact that it
actually unites
everything they're very small they're
very very small and they're very big
it's only through the very big that the
very small gets formed like basically
every atom of gold
results from the fusion that happened
of you know increasingly large particles
before that explosion that then
disperses it through the cosmos
and it's only through understanding the
very large that we understand very small
and vice versa
and that's in space then there's the
time direction as you are
watching the kilimanjaro mountain you
can kind of
look back through time to when that
volcano was exploding
and you know growing out of the tectonic
forces
as you drive through death valley you
see these mountains
on their side and these layers
of history exposed
we are aware of the
eons that have happened on earth and the
tectonic movements on earth
the same way that we're aware of the big
bang
and the you know early evolution of the
cosmos and we can also see forward in
time
as to where the universe is heading we
can see you know apophis
in 2068 coming over looking ahead in
time i mean that would be magician stuff
you know in ancient times so what i love
about humanity and its role in the
universe
is that you know if there's a god
watching
he's like finally somebody figured it
out i've been
building all these beautiful things and
somebody can appreciate it and figured
me out from god's perspective meaning
like become aware
of yeah you know yeah so it's kind of
interesting so
to think of the world in this way as
layers and us humans
are able to convert those layers into
ideas that they
you can then like combine right so we're
doing some kind of conversion
exactly exactly and last time you asked
me about
whether we live in a simulation for
example i mean
realize that we are living in a
simulation
we are the reality that we're in without
any sort of
person programming this is a simulation
like basically
what happens inside your skull there's
this integration of sensory inputs
which are translated into perceptory
signals which are then translated into a
conceptual model of the world
around you and that exercise
is happening seamlessly and yet
you know if you if you think about sort
of again this whole simulation and neo
um analogy you can think of the reality
that we live in as a matrix
as the matrix but we've actually broken
through the matrix
we've actually traversed the layers we
didn't have to take a pill like we
didn't nick
you know morpheus didn't have to show up
to basically give us the blue pill or
the red pill
we were able to sufficiently evolve
cognitively
through the hardware explosion and
sufficiently involve
scientifically through the software
explosion to basically get at
breaking through the matrix realizing
that we live in a matrix
and realizing that we are this thing in
there
and yet that thing in there has a
consciousness that
lives through all these layers and i
think we're the only species we're the
only thing that we even can think of
that has actually done that has
sort of permeated space and time
scales and layers of abstraction
plowing through them and realizing what
we're really
really made of and the next frontier is
of course cognition
so we understand so much of the cosmos
so much of the stuff around us
but the stuff inside here finding the
basis for the soul
finding the basis for the ego for the
self
the self-awareness when do when does the
spark happen
that basically sort of makes you you
i mean that's you know really the next
frontier so so in terms of these
peeling off layers of complexity
somewhere between the cognitive layer
and the reasoning layer
or the computational layer there's still
some stuff to be figured out there
and i think that's the final frontier of
sort of completing our journey through
that matrix
and maybe duplicating it in the
in other versions of ourselves through
ai
which is another very exciting uh
possibility
what i love about ai and the way that it
operates right now
is the fact that it is unpredictable
there's emergent behavior in our
cognitively
capable artificial systems
that we can certainly model but we don't
encode directly and that's a key
difference so we like to say oh
of course this is not really intelligent
because we coded it up
and we just put in these little
parameters there and there's like you
know
six billion parameters and once you've
learned them you know we kind of
understand the layers
but that's an oversimplification it's
it's like saying oh of course humans we
understand humans they're just made out
of neurons and
you know layers of cortex and there's a
visual
area and there's a but but every human
is encoded
by a ridiculously small number of genes
compared to the complexity of our
cognitive apparatus
20 000 genes is really not that much out
of which a tiny little fraction
are in fact encoding all of our
cognitive functions
the rest is emergent behavior
the rest is the you know
the the the cortical layers doing their
thing
in the same way that when we build you
know these conversational systems or
these cognitive systems or these deep
learning
systems we put the architecture in place
but then they do their thing
and in some ways that's creating
something that has its own identity
that's creating something that's not
just oh yeah it's not the
early ai where if you hadn't programmed
what happens in the
grocery bags when you have both cold and
hot and hard and
soft you know the system wouldn't know
what to do no no
you basically now just program the
primitives and then he learns from that
so even though the origins are humble
just like it is for our genetic code
for ai even though the origins are
humble the
the uh the result of it being deployed
into the world is infinitely complex
and that's and yet
there's not uh it's not yet able to be
cognizant of all the other layers in uh
of its you know it's not
it's not able to think about
space and time it's not able to think
about the hardware in which it runs the
electricity on which it runs
yet so so if you look at humans
we basically have the same cognitive
architecture as monkeys
as the great apes it's just a ton more
of it
if you look at um gpt3 versus gpd2
again it's the same architecture just
more of it
and yet it's able to do so much more
yeah so if you start thinking about sort
of what's the future of that
gpt 455 do you really need fundamentally
different architectures or do you just
need a ton more hardware
and we do have a ton more hardware like
these systems are nowhere near
what humans have between our ears
so you know there's something to be said
about
stay tuned for emergent behavior
we keep thinking that general
intelligence might just be forever away
but it could just simply be that we just
need a ton more hardware
and that humans are just not that
different from the great apes
except for just a ton more of it yeah
it's interesting that in the
ai community maybe it is a human-centric
fear
but the notion that gpt 10 will be
will achieve general intelligence is
something that people shy away from
that there has to be something totally
different and new added to this
and yet it's not seriously considered
that
um this this very simple
thing this very simple architecture when
scaled might
be the thing that achieves super
intelligence and people think the same
way about humanity and human
consciousness they're like oh
consciousness might be quantum or it
might be you know some
some non-physical thing and it's like
or it could just be a lot more of the
same hardware
that now is sufficiently capable of
self-awareness
just because it has the neurons to do it
so maybe the
consciousness that is so elusive
is an emergent behavior of
you basically string together all these
cognitive capabilities
that come from running from seeing for
reacting from
predicting the movement of the fly as
you're catching it through the air
all of these things are just like great
lookup tables encoded in a giant neural
network
i mean i'm oversimplifying of course the
complexity and the diversity of the
different types of excitatory inhibitory
neurons
the waveforms that sort of shine through
the
you know the the connections across all
these different layers
the amalgamation of signals etc the
brain is enormously complex
i mean of course but again it's a small
number of primitives
encoded by a tiny number of genes which
are
self-organized and shaped by
their environment babies that are
growing up today are listening to
language
from conception basically as soon as the
auditory apparatus forms it's already
getting shaped
to the types of signals that are out in
the real world today
so it's not just like oh have an
egyptian be born and then ship them over
it's like no that egyptian would be
listening
in to the complex of the world and then
getting born and sort of seeing
just how much more complex the world is
so it's a combination
of the underlying hardware which
if you think about as a geneticist in my
view the hardware
gives you an upper bound of cognitive
capabilities
but it's the environment that makes
those capabilities shine and reach their
maxima so we're a combination of
nature and nurture the nature is our
genes
and our cognitive apparatus and the
nurture
is the richness of the environment that
makes that cognitive apparatus reach
its potential and we are so far
from reaching our full potential so far
i think that kids being born 100 years
from now
they'll be looking at us now and saying
what primitive
educational systems they had i can't
believe people were not wired into this
you know virtual reality from birth as
we are now because like
they're clearly inferior and so forth so
i basically think that
our environment will continue exploding
and our cognitive capabilities it's not
like oh we're only using two percent of
our brain that's ridiculous of course
we're using 100 of our brain
but it's still constrained by how
complex our environment is
so the hardware will remain the same but
the software
in a quickly advancing environment the
software will make a huge difference in
the nature of like the human experience
the human condition
it's fascinating to think that humans
will look very different 100 years from
now
just because the environment changed
even though we're still the same great
apes
the the descendant of apes at the core
of this is kind of a notion of ideas
that uh i don't know if you're there's a
lot of people that's
including you eloquently about this
topic but richard dawkins talks about
the notion of memes and let's say
this notion of ideas
you know multiplying selecting in the
minds of humans
do you ever think from about ideas from
the from that perspective
ideas as organisms themselves that are
breeding in the minds of humans
i love the concept of memes i love the
concept of
this horizontal transfer of ideas and
sort of permeating through
through you know our layer of
interconnected
neural networks so you can think of sort
of the cognitive
space that has now connected all of
humanity
where we are now one giant
information and idea sharing network
well beyond what was thought to be ever
capable
when the concept of a meme was created
by richard dawkins
so but i want to take that concept just
you know into another twist which is
the horizontal transfer of
humans with fellowships
and the fact that as people apply to mit
from around the world
there's a selection that happens not
just for
their ideas but also for the cognitive
hardware
that came up with those ideas so we
don't just ship ideas around anymore
they don't evolve in a vacuum
the ideas themselves influence the
distribution of cognitive systems
i.e humans and brains around the planet
yeah we ship them to different locations
based on their properties that's exactly
right
so so those cognitive systems that think
of
you know physics for example might go to
cern and those that think of
genomics might go to the broad institute
and those that think of computer science
might go to i don't know stanford or cmu
or mit
and you basically have this co-evolution
now of
memes and ideas and the cognitive
conversational systems that love these
ideas and feed on these ideas and
understand these ideas and appreciate
these ideas
now coming together so you basically
have
students coming to boston to study
because that's the place where
these type of cognitive systems thrive
and they're selected based on their
cognitive output and their idea output
but once they get into that place the
boiling and interbreeding of these memes
becomes so much more frequent that what
comes out of it
is so far beyond if ideas were evolving
in a vacuum
of an already established hardware
cognitive interconnection system of the
planet
where now you basically have
the ideas shaping the distribution of
these systems
and then the genetics kick in as well
you basically have now
these people who came to be a student
kind of like myself who now stuck around
and are now professors bringing up our
own
genetically encoded and genetically
related
cognitive systems mine are eight six and
three years old
who are now growing up in an environment
surrounded by
other cognitive systems of a similar age
with parents who love these types of
thinking and ideas
and you basically have a whole
interbreeding now of
genetically selected transfer
of cognitive systems where the genes
and the memes are co-evolving the same
soup
of ever improving knowledge and societal
inter-fertilization cross-virtualization
of these ideas
so that this beautiful image so these
are shipping these actual
meat cognitive systems to physical
locations they they tend to uh cluster
in uh the biology ones cluster in a
certain building too so like within that
there's
there's uh there's clusters on top of
clusters type of clusters what about
in the online world is that do you also
see that kind of because people now
form groups on the internet that they
stick together so they
they can sort of uh these cognitive
systems can
collect themselves and uh breed together
uh on in in different layers of spaces
it doesn't just have to be physical
space
absolutely absolutely so basically
there's the physical rearrangement
but there's also the conglomeration of
the same cognitive system
doesn't need to be a human it doesn't
need to belong to only one community
yeah so yes you might be a member of the
computer science department but you can
also hang out in the biology department
but you might also go online online into
i don't know poetry department uh
readings and so forth or you might be
part of a group that only has 12 people
in the world but that are connected
through their ideas
and are now interbreeding these ideas in
a whole other way
so this um this coevolution of genes and
memes
is not just physically instantiated it's
also sort of rearranged
you know in this cognitive uh space as
well
and uh and sometimes these cognitive
systems hold conferences and they all
get gather around and there's like one
of them is like talking and they're all
like listening and then
you discuss and then they have free
lunch and so on no but
but then that's where you find students
where you know
when when i go to a conference i go
through the posters where i'm on a
mission
basically my mission is to read and
understand what every poster is about
and for a few of them i'll dive deeply
and understand everything but i make it
a point to just go post after posting in
order
to read all of them and i find some gems
and students that i speak to that
sometimes eventually join my lab
and then sort of you're you're sort of
creating this permeation
of you know the transfer
of ideas of ways of thinking
and very often of moral values of
social structures of you know just more
imperceptible properties of these
cognitive systems that simply just cling
together
basically you know there's i have the
luxury
at mit of not just choosing smart people
but choosing
smart people who i get along with
who are generous and friendly
and creative and smart and you know
excited and childish in their
in you know uninhibited behaviors and so
forth so
you basically can choose yourself to
surround
you can choose to surround yourself with
people who are not only cognitively
compatible but also you know
imperceptibly through the meta cognitive
systems
compatible and again when i say
compatible not all the same
sometimes you know sometimes all the
time
the teams are made out of complementary
components not just compatible but
very often complementary so in my own
team i have a diversity of
students who come from very different
backgrounds
there's a whole spectrum of biology to
computation of course but within biology
there's a lot of realms within
computation there's a lot of rounds
and what makes us click so well together
is the fact that not only do we have a
common mission a common passion
and a common you know view of
the world but that were complementary in
our skills
in our angles with which we accommodate
and so so forth and that's sort of what
makes it click yeah it's fascinating
that the
the the stickiness of multiple cognitive
systems together
includes both the commonality so you
meet because you're
there's some common thing but you stick
together
because you're dif different in all the
useful ways
yeah yeah and my wife and i i mean we
adore each other like to pieces
but we're also extremely different in
many ways and that's
beautiful but i love that about
about us i love the fact that you know
i'm like living out there in the
you know world of ideas and i forget
what day it is
and she's like well at 8 am the kids
better be to school
and uh you know yeah i do get yelled at
but but i need it basically i need her
as much as she needs me and she
loves interacting with me and talking i
mean you know last night we were talking
about
this and i showed her the questions and
we were bouncing ideas of each other
and it was just beautiful like we
basically have these you know
basically cognitive you know
let it all loose kind of dates where you
know we just
bring papers and we're like you know
bouncing ideas etc so
you know we have extremely different
perspectives but
very common you know goals and
interests and anyway what do you make of
the communication mechanism that we
humans use to share those ideas because
like one essential element of all of
this is not just that we're able to
have these ideas but we're also able to
share them
we tend to maybe you can correct me but
we seem to use
language to share the ideas maybe we
share them in some much deeper way than
language i don't know
but what do you make of this whole
mechanism and how fundamental it is to
the human condition so some people will
tell you that your language
dictates your thoughts and your thoughts
cannot form outside language
i tend to disagree i see
uh thoughts as much more abstract
as you know basically when i dream i
don't dream in words
i dream in shapes and forms and you know
three-dimensional space with extreme
detail
i was describing so when i wake up in
the middle of the night i actually
record my dreams sometimes i write them
down in a dropbox file
uh other times i'll just dictate them in
you know audio
and um my wife was giving me a massage
the other day because like my
left side was frozen and i started
playing
the recording and as i was listening to
it
i was like i don't remember any of that
and i was like of course
and then the entire thing came back but
then there's no way any other person
could have
recreated that entire sort of you know
three-dimensional
uh shape and dream and concept and in
the same way when i'm thinking of ideas
there's so many ideas i can't put two
words i mean i will describe him with a
thousand words but
the idea itself is much more precise or
much more sort of
abstract or much more something you know
difference either
less abstract or more abstract and it's
either you know
basically the there's just a projection
that happens
from the three-dimensional ideas into
let's say a one-dimensional language
and the language certainly gives you the
apparatus to think about
concepts that you didn't realize existed
before
and with my team we often create new
words i'm like well
now we're going to call this the
regulatory plexus of a gene and that
gives us now the language to sort of
build on that as one concept that you
then build upon with all kinds of other
other things so there's this
co-evolution again of ideas and language
but they're not one-to-one uh with each
other
now let's talk about language itself
words
sentences this is a very
distant construct from where language
actually begun
so if you look at how we communicate
as i'm speaking my eyes are shining
and my face is changing through all
kinds of emotions
and my entire body composition posture
is reshaped and my intonation
the pauses that i make the softer and
the louder and
this and that are conveying so much more
information
and if you look at early human language
and if you look at how you know the
great apes communicate with each other
there's a lot of granting there's a lot
of postering there's a lot of emotions
there's a lot of sort of shrieking etc
they have a lot of components of
our human language just not the words
so i think of human communication
as combining the ape
component but also of course the you
know gpt3 component
so basically there's the cognitive layer
and the reasoning layer that we share
with different parts of our relatives
there's the ai relatives
but there's also the grunting relatives
and
what i love about humanity is that we
have both we're not just a
conversational system
we're a grunting emotionally charged
you know weirdly intercon
connected system that also has the
ability to reason
and when when we communicate with each
other
there's so much more than just language
there's so much more than just words
it does seem like we're able to somehow
transfer even more than the
the body language it seems that in the
room with us
is always a giant knowledge base
of like shared experiences different
perspectives on those experiences but
i don't know the knowledge of who the
last three four presidents in the united
states was and
just all the you know 911 the tragedies
in 911 all the
all the beautiful and uh terrible things
that happen in the world they're
somehow both in our minds and somehow
enrich the ability to transfer
information
and what i love about it is i can i can
talk to you about 2001 audience of space
and mention a very specific scene and
that evokes
all these feelings that you had when you
first watched it we're both visualizing
that
maybe in different ways exactly but in
that yeah
and not only that but the feeling
uh is brought back up just like you said
with the dreams
we both have that feeling arise in some
form exactly as you bring up the
exact you know uh facing his own
mortality
yeah it's fascinating that we're able to
do that but i don't know
now let's let's talk about neural link
for a second so what's the concept of
generally the concept of neural link is
that i'm going to take
whatever knowledge is encoded in my
brain directly transfer it into your
brain
so this is a beautiful fascinating and
extremely sort of you know appealing
concept
but i see a lot of challenges
surrounding that
the first one is we have no idea how to
even begin to understand
how knowledge is encoded in a person's
brain
i mean i told you about this paper that
we had recently with liquitai
and asaf marco that basically was
looking at these
engrams that are formed with
combinations of neurons that co-fire
when a stimulus happens
where we can go into a mouse and select
those neurons that fire by marking them
and then see what happens when they
first fire and then select the neurons
that fire again when the experience is
repeated
these are the recall neurons and then
there's the
the memory consolidation neurons so
we're starting to understand a little
bit of sort of the distributed
nature of knowledge and coding and
experience in coding
in the human brain and in the mouse
brain and
the concept that we'll understand that
sufficiently one day
to be able to take a snapshot of
what does that seem from dave losing his
mind
of how losing his mind and talking to
dave
um how is that seen encoded in your
mind imagine the complexity of that but
now imagine
suppose that we solve this problem and
the next enormous challenge is how do i
go and modify the next person's brain
to now create the same exact neural
connections
so that's an enormous challenge right
there so basically it's not just reading
it's not writing and again
what if something goes wrong i don't
want to even think about that
that's number two and number three who
says
that the way that you encode dave i'm
losing my mind
and i encode dave i'm losing my mind
is anywhere near each other basically
maybe the way that i'm encoding it
is twisted with my childhood memories of
running through
you know the pebbles in greece and yours
is twisted with your childhood memories
growing up in russia and there's no way
that i can take my encoding and put it
into your brain because it'll
a mess things up and b be incompatible
with your own unique experiences so
that's telepathic communication from
human to humor it's fascinating
you're you're reminding us that uh
there's there's uh two biological
systems on both ends of that
communication
and the one the easier i guess may be
half
as difficult a thing to do and the hope
with neural link is that
we can communicate with an ai system so
yeah where one side of that is a little
bit
yeah more controllable but
but even just that is is exceptionally
difficult let's talk about
two two new neuronal systems talking to
each other suppose that gpt4
tells gpd3 hey give me all your
knowledge right
it's ready that's hilarious i have ten
times more hardware i'm ready just feed
me what's gbt3 going to do
is it going to say oh here's my 10
billion parameters
no no way the simplest way and perhaps
the fastest way for gpd3 to transfer all
this knowledge to its older body that
has a lot more hardware
is to regenerate every single possible
human sentence that he can possibly
yes create keep talking keep talking
and just re-encode it all together so
maybe what language does
is exactly that it's taking one
generative cognitive model
it's running it forward to emit
utterances that kind of make sense in my
cognitive frame
and it's re-encoding them into yours
through
the parsing of that same language and i
think the conversation might
might actually be the most efficient way
to do it so not just
talking but uh interactive so talking
back and forth
yeah asking questions interrupting so
gpth4 will constantly be interrupted
is also that as we're interrupting each
other
there's all kinds of misinterpretations
that happen
that you know as basically when my
students speak
i will often know that i'm
misunderstanding what they're saying
and i'll be like hold that thought for a
second let me tell you what i think i
understood which i know is different
what you said then i'll say that and
then someone else
in the same zoom meeting will basically
say well
you know here's another way to think
about what you just said and then by the
third iteration we're somewhere
completely different
that if we could actually communicate
with
full you know neural network parameters
back and forth of that knowledge and
idea and coding
would be far inferior because
the re-encoding with our own as we said
last time emotional baggage
and cognitive baggage from our unique
experiences
through our shared experiences
distinct encodings in the context of all
our unique experiences
is leading to so much more
diversity of perspectives and again
going back to this whole concept of this
entire network of all of human cognitive
systems connected to each other
and sort of how ideas and memes permeate
through that
that's sort of what really creates a
whole new level
of human experience through
this reasoning layer and this
computational
layer that obviously lives on top of our
cognitive layer
so you're one of these
aforementioned cognitive systems
mortal but uh
thoughtful and you're connected to a
bunch like you said students
uh your wife your kids what do you
in your brief time here on earth this is
a meaning of life episode
so uh what do you hope this world will
remember you as what do you hope your
legacy will be
i don't think of legacy as much
as maybe most people things
legacy oh it's kind of funny i'm
consciously living the present
yes many students tell me you know oh
give us some career advice i'm like i'm
the wrong person
i've never made a career plan i still
have to make one
i um it's funny
to be both experiencing the past and the
present and the future but also
consciously living in the present
and just you know there's a conscious
decision we can make to not worry about
all that
which again goes back to the i'm the
lucky one kind of thing
of living in the present and being happy
winning and being happy losing and um
there's a certain freedom that comes
with that but again a certain
um sort of i don't know ephemerity
of living for the present
but if you if you step back from all of
that where
basically my my current modus operandis
is live for the present make you know
every day the best you can make and just
make the local blip of local maxima of
the universe
of the awesomeness of the planet and the
town
and the family that we live in both
academic family and
you know biological family um
make it a little more awesome by being
generous to your friends being generous
to the people around you being
you know kind to your enemies and uh you
know
just showing level around you can't be
upset at people
if you truly love them if somebody yells
at you and
insults you every time you say the
slightest thing and yet when you see
them
you just see them with love it's a
beautiful feeling it's like
you know i'm feeling exactly like when i
look at my three-year-old who's like
screaming
even though i love her and i want her
good she's still screaming and saying
no no no no no and i'm like i love you i
genuinely
love you but i can i can sort of kind of
see that your brain is kind of stuck
in that little you know mode of anger
and you know there's plenty of people
out there who don't like me
and i see them with love as the child
that is stuck in a cognitive state
that they're eventually going to snap
out of or maybe not and that's okay
so there's that aspect of sort of you
know experiencing
you know life with the best intentions
and you know i love when i'm wrong
i i had a friend who was like one of the
smartest people i've ever met
who would basically say oh i love it
when i'm wrong because it makes me feel
human
and it's so beautiful i mean she's
really one of the smartest people i've
ever met
and she was like oh it's such a good
feeling and
i love being wrong but there's
you know there's something about
self-improvement there's something about
sort of how do i
not make the most mistakes but attempt
the most rights
and do the fewest wrongs but with the
full knowledge that this will happen
that's one aspect so so so through this
life in the present what's really funny
is and that's something that i've
experienced more and more
really thanks to you and through this
podcast
is this enormous number of people who
will basically comment
wow i've been following this guy for so
many years now
or wow this guy has inspired so many of
us in computational biology
and so forth i'm like i don't know any
of that
but i'm only discovering this now
through this sort of
sharing our emotional states and our
cognitive states
with a wider audience where suddenly
i'm sort of realizing that wow maybe
i've had a legacy
yes like basically i've trained
generations of students from mit
and i've put all of my courses freely
online
since 2001 so basically all of my video
recordings of my lectures have been
online since 2001.
so countless generations of people from
across the world
will meet me at a conference and say
like i was at this conference where
somebody heard my voice it's like
i know this voice i've been listening to
your lectures yes and
it's just such a beautiful thing where
like we're sharing
widely and who knows which students will
get where
from whatever they catch out of these
lectures even if what they catch is just
inspiration
and passion and drive so
there's this intangible you know
legacy quote-unquote that every one of
us has through the people we touch
one of my friends from undergrad
basically told me oh my mom remembers
you vividly from when she came to campus
i'm like i didn't even meet her she's
like no but
she she sort of saw you interacting with
people and said wow
he's exuding this positive energy and
there's there's that aspect of sort of
just motivating people with your
kindness with your passion with your
generosity
and with your you know just selflessness
uh
of of you know just just just give
doesn't matter where it goes
i i've been to conferences where
basically people you know i'll ask them
a question
and then they'll come back or like there
was a company where i asked somebody
question they said
oh in fact this entire project was
inspired by your question three years
ago
at the same conference yes i'm like wow
and then on top of that there's also the
ripple effects of the years speaking to
the direct
influence of inspiration or education
but there's also like
the follow-on things that happened to
that and there's this ripple that
through
from you just this one individual and
from every one of us
from everyone that's what i love about
humanity the fact that
every one of us shares genes
and genetic variants with very recent
ancestors
with everyone else so even if i die
tomorrow
my genes are still shared through my
cousins and through my uncles and
through my
you know immediate family and of course
i'm lucky enough to have my own children
but even if you don't your genes are
still permeating through
all of the layers of your family so your
genes will have the legacy there yeah or
every one of us
yeah number two our ideas are constantly
intermingling with each other
so there's no person living in the
planet
100 years from now who will not be
directly impacted by
everyone on the planet living here today
yeah through genetic inheritance
and through meme inheritance that's cool
to think that your ideas
manolas callus would touch
would uh touch every single person on
this planet
it's interesting but not just mine joe
smith who's looking at this right now
his ideas
will also touch everybody so there's
this interconnectedness of humanity
and and then i'm also a professor so my
day job
is legacy my day job is training not
just
the thousands of people who watch my
videos on the web but the people who are
actually in my class who basically come
to mit to
learn from a bunch of us
like the cognitive systems that were
shipped to this particular location and
who will then disperse back into all of
their home countries
yeah that's that's what makes america
the beacon of the world
we don't just export you know
goods we export people cognitive systems
we
we export people who are born here
and we also export training that people
born elsewhere will come here to get
and will then disseminate not just
whatever knowledge they got but whatever
ideals they learned
and i think that's something that's a
legacy of the us that
you cannot stop with political isolation
you cannot stop with economic isolation
that's something that will continue to
happen through all the people we've
touched through our universities
so there's the students who took my
classes who are basically now going off
and teaching their classes
and i've trained generations of
computational biologists no one in
genomics who's gone through mit
hasn't taken my class so basically
there's this impact
through i mean there's so many people in
biotech who are like hey i took your
class that's what got me into the field
like
15 years ago it's just so beautiful yes
and then
there's the academic family that i have
so the students who are actually
studying with me who are my trainees
so this sort of mentorship of ancient
greece these
so i basically have an academic family
and
we are a family there's this
such strong connection this bond of
you're part of the kelly's family so i
have a biological family
at home and i have an academic family on
campus and that academic family
has given me great grandchildren already
yes
so i've trained people who are now
professors at stanford tmu
harvard you know what you i mean
everywhere in the uh
on the world and these people have now
trained people
who are now having their own faculty
jobs
so there's basically people who see me
as their academic grandfather
and it's just so beautiful because you
don't have to wait for the 18 years of
cognitive
you know hardware development to to sort
of
have amazing conversation with people
these are fully grown humans
fully grown adult who are you know
cognitively
super ready and who are shaped by and
you know i see some of these beautiful
papers i'm like
i can see the touch of our lab in those
favors it's just so beautiful because
you're like
i've spent hours with these people
teaching them not just how to do a paper
but how to
think and this whole concept of
you know the first paper that we write
together is
an experience with every one of these
students so
you know i always tell them to write the
whole first draft and they know that i
will rewrite every word
but but the act of them writing it and
what i do is these like joint editing
sessions where i'm like let's co-edit
and with this co-editing we basically
have um
creative destruction so i share my zoom
screen
and i'm just thinking out loud as i'm
doing this and they're learning from
that process as opposed to like
come back two days later and they see a
bunch of red on a page i'm sort of
well that's not how you write this
that's not how you think about this
that's not
you know what's the point like this
morning i was having a i yes this
morning between six and eight a.m
i had a two-hour meeting going through
one of these papers
and then saying what's the point here
why why do you even show that it's just
a bunch of
points on a graph no what you have to do
is extract the meaning
do the homework for them and there's
this
nurturing this mentorship that sort of
creates now
a legacy which is infinite because
they've now gone off on the you know and
all of that is just humanity
then of course it's the papers i write
because yes
my day job is training students but it's
a research university
the way that they learn is through the
men's and manus
mind and hand it's the practical
training of actually doing research
and that research is a beneficial side
effect
of having these awesome papers that will
now
tell other people how to think there's
this paper we just posted recently on
med archive and one of the most generous
and eloquent comments about it was like
wow this is a master class
in scientific writing in analysis
in biological interpretation and so so
forth it's just so fulfilling from a
person i've never met or first say the
title of the paper branch
i don't remember the title but it's
single cell dissection of schizophrenia
reveals and so the two the two points
that we found was this whole
transcriptional resilience like there's
some individuals
who are schizophrenic but whose
they have an additional cell type or
initial cell state which we believe is
protective
and that cell state when they have it
will cause other cells to have normal
gene expression patterns
it's beautiful yeah and then that's that
cell
is connected with some of the pv
interneurons that are basically sending
these
inhibitory brain waves through the brain
and there basically there's a there's
another component of
there's a set of master regulators that
we discovered
who are controlling many of the genes
that are differentially expressed
and these master regulators are
themselves genetic targets
of schizophrenia and they are themselves
involved in both
synaptic connectivity and also in early
brain development so there's this sort
of interconnectedness between
synaptic development axes and also this
transcription resilience so
i mean we basically made up a title that
combines all these concepts you have all
these concepts all these
people working together and ultimately
these minds condense it down into a
beautifully
exactly little document that lives on
and that document now has its own life
yeah our work has a hundred and a
hundred and twenty thousand citations i
mean
that's not just people who read it these
are people who used it
to write something based on it yeah i
mean that to me
is is just so fulfilling
to basically say wow i've touched people
so
i i don't think of my legacy as i live
every day i just think of the beauty of
the present
and the power of interconnectedness and
just i feel like a kid in a candy shop
where i'm just like constantly you know
where do i what what package do i open
first
and um you know the lucky one
a jack of all trades a master of none i
think
uh for a meaning of life episode we
would be amiss if we did not have at
least
a poem or two do you mind if we uh
end in a couple of poems maybe a happy
maybe a sad one
i would love i would love that so thank
you for the luxury
the first one is kind of um
i remember uh when you were talking with
eric weinstein
about um this comment
of leonard cohen yes that says but you
don't really
care for music do ya yeah in hallelujah
that's basically kind of like mocking
its reader yeah so one of my poems is a
little like that
so i had just broken up with
you know my girlfriend and there's this
other friend who was coming to visit me
and she said i will not come unless you
write me a poem
and uh i was like writing a form on
demand
so this this poem is called write me a
poem
it goes write me a poem she said with a
smile
make sure it's pretty romantic and
rhymes make sure it's worthy of that
bold flame
that love uniting us beyond a mere game
and she took off without more words
rushed for the bus
and travelled the world a poem i thought
this is sublime what better way for
passing the time
what better way to count up the hours
before she comes back to my lonely tower
waiting for joy to fill up my heart
let's write a poem for when we're apart
how does a poem start i inquired give me
a topic
hook up a style throw in some cute words
oh here and there
throw in some passion love and despair
love
three eggs one pound of flour three cups
of water
and bake for an hour love is no recipe
as i understand
you can't just cook up a poem on demand
and as i was twisting all this in my
mind
i looked at the page by golly it rhymed
three roses white chocolate vanilla
powder some beautiful rhymes and maybe a
flower
no be romantic the young girl insisted
do this do that don't be so silly
you must believe it straight from your
heart if you don't feel it we're better
apart
oh my sweet thing what can i say you
bring me the sun
all night and all day you're the stars
and the moon and the birds way up high
you're my evening sweet song my morning
blue sky
you are my muse your spell has me caught
you bring me my voice and scatter my
thoughts
to put love in writing in vain i can try
but when i'm with you my wings want to
fly
so i put down the pen and drop my
defenses
give myself to you and fill up my senses
the baffle king composing that was
beautiful
what i love about it is that i did not
bring up a dictionary of rhymes i did
not sort of
work hard so basically when i write
poems i just type
i never go back i just so when my
brain gets into that mode it actually
happens like i wrote it
oh wow so the rhymes just kind of
becomes it's an emergent phenomenon
phenomenon i just get into that mode
and then it comes out that's a beautiful
one and it's it's
basically um you know as you as you got
it it's basically saying it's no recipe
and then i'm starting
throwing the recipes and as i'm writing
it i'm like you know so it's
it's very introspective in this whole uh
concert so anyway there's another one
many years earlier
that um is you know
darker it's basically this whole concept
of let's be friends
i was like ugh
no let's be friends just like you know
so the last words are shout out i love
you or send me to hell
so uh the the title is burn me tonight
lie to me baby lie to me now
tell me you love me break me a vow give
me a sweet word
i promise a kiss give me the world a
sweet taste to miss
don't let me lay here inert ugly cold
with nothing sweet felt and nothing
harsh told give me some
hope false foolish yet kind make me
regret
i'll leave you behind don't pity my soul
or torture it right treat it with hatred
start up a fight for it's from mildness
that my soul dies
when you cover your passion in a bland
friend's disguise
kiss me now baby show me your passion
turn off the light and rip off your
fashion
give me my life's joy this one night
burn all my matches for one blazing
light
don't think of tomorrow and let today
fade don't try and protect me from
love's cutting blade
your razor will always rip off my veins
don't spare me the passion
to spare me the pains kiss me now honey
or spit in my face
throw me an insult i'll gladly embrace
tell me now clearly that you never cared
say it now loudly like you never dared
i'm ready to hear it i'm ready to die
i'm ready to burn
and start a new life i'm ready to face
the rough burning truth
rather than waste the rest of my youth
so tell me my lover
should i stay or go the answer to love
is one yes or no
there's no i like you no let's be
friends shout out i love you
or send me to hell
i don't think there's a better way to
end
a discussion of the meaning of life
whatever the heck the meaning is
uh go all in as that poem says manolas
thank you so much for talking today
thanks i look forward to next time
thanks for listening to this
conversation with manolas kellis
and thank you to our sponsors grammarly
which is a service for checking spelling
grammar sentence structure and
readability athletic greens
the all-in-one drink that i start every
day with to cover all my nutritional
bases
cash app the app i use to send money to
friends
please check out the sponsors in the
description to get a discount and to
support this podcast
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it with five stars and
have a podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
at lex friedman and now let me leave you
with some words from douglas adams
in his book hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy
on the planet earth man had always
assumed
that he was more intelligent than
dolphins because he had achieved so much
the wheel new york wars
and so on whilst all the dolphins had
ever done
was muck about in the water having a
good time
but conversely the dolphins had always
believed
that they were far more intelligent than
man for precisely
the same reasons thank you for listening
and hope to see you
next time